hi uh good morning everyone thank you
for being here um i'm luanna
i just obtained my phd from the
electrical engineering department at
upenn
i'm now a research fellow here at
simon's i'm going to be a postdoc at
foxy in the spring and then i'll be
joining the applied math department at
hopkins next summer
and today i want to talk about some of
the research that i did on machine
learning on large scale graphs
so to motivate my talk i have to answer
two preliminary
questions which are the why and the how
the why is why do we care
about machine learning large scale
graphs and that question has a
relatively easy answer the answer being
that the need to process information on
very large graphs arises in a wide range
of applications so for example i have
two examples of applications where this
need arises uh one of them is
this product similarity graph
where the nodes represent products the
edge weights represent product
similarities
and we can define a signal on top of
this graph which is given by the ratings
that some user or consumer has given to
some of these products
and then given some of these ratings
what we want is what we want to leverage
the breadth structure to fill in the
missing ratings and make
pointed product recommendations right
another example is this uh
problem here on the right where we have
a graph that is given by a team of
robots or agents that we want to control
in a distributed manner
and uh the the what we want them to do
here is we want them to flock so fi fly
at the same velocity while avoiding
collisions
but the catch here is that
communications are limited by proximity
because we want to limit interference
and so any control policy that we come
up with has to respect this information
structure that is given by this by this
graph
so both of these problems are examples
of problems where
we can motivate the use of learning and
learning has indeed been shown to
outperform other existing uh solutions
and they're also examples of problems
where they become more interesting as
these graphs
increase right so if we have
a lot of like say in the order of
thousands of products in the order of
hundreds of robots but the issue is that
machine learning models become harder to
train or to learn for these problems as
these graphs grow
we know that machine learning works well
in moderately sized graphs but it's
harder to to train them on these large
graphs
now the how question which is how do we
do machine learning on large scale
graphs it also has a relatively easy
answer
and uh the answer from that comes from
the ample amount of empirical and
theoretical evidence to support using
neural networks
the issue is that standard by which i
mean fully connected neural networks uh
they're not scalable the neural networks
that we know are scalable are
convolutional neural networks that we
use to process uh time signals and and
images and that we know scale well to to
large data of that type
however convolutional neural networks
only operate on regular with like data
such as this data here on the left while
the information that we want to process
lies on
irregular structures
better modeled by these graphs by graphs
such as the one on the on the right
right and so this is this observation
provides both a challenge and a solution
right the challenge is that we have to
find some way to extend convolutions and
convolutional neural networks to this
type of of data the solution is that
people have been doing that for
um half a decade now or so by defining
graph convolutions and and graph neural
networks
so in my research i am interested in two
research questions the first one is that
we have empirically observed that
graphene or network scale but we don't
know why they do
and the second question is whether we
can leverage the success of gnns on
moderate size graphs to generate success
at a large scale and i'll be clear more
clear about this point in a couple of
minutes
and to answer both of these questions
we should turn to graph limits and why
should we turn to graph limits well
because limits they reveal the intrinsic
dimension of of the data which is
typically smaller than than the graph
size
and this would help explain why gnns
scale well to to large data large graph
data
and second because if we're able to
characterize the convergence of graphs
to this to this graph limit
maybe we'll learn things that will
both help us understand whether gnns
converge to a limit on these graphs and
maybe will tell us something that will
you know can be exploited to facilitate
the training of of gnns for these large
scale graph applications
now as we have you know heard about um
extensively last week
graphs indeed have limit objects that
effectively uh limit their
dimensionality and one such uh limit
object is the grapho
which i have an example here on this
slide of inertia's renigrafon and this
reform can be thought of as a graph uh
with an uncountable number of nodes it's
a kernel a bounded symmetric kernel
and what we see when we look at
sequences of graphs that converge to
graphone is that the overall structure
of these graphs is also converging to
the overall structure of the reform and
in this case here we can
really see that if we look at the 200
node graph and at the limit graph on
right the structures become increasingly
similar
this is a i should say that this is a
very simple example of graphone but
this convergence of structure and
and you know many other properties uh
holds for more interesting uh examples
of graphs and reforms as well
now um you know it's good to know that
graphs converge to a limit right and in
this case we're focusing on the graph
but this convergence of graphs doesn't
necessarily imply that convolutions and
therefore the neural networks converge
to limits on on on the limits of these
graphs right on the graphone
and the reason for that is that you know
convergence of convolutions in euclidean
domains is actually related to sampling
and sampling is very regular it depends
on geometry and so it won't translate
verbatim to to graphs right because they
have these irregular structures as we
can see here
from the sequence of of product graphs
and so
whether graph convolutions and graph
neural networks converge to
limit objects on the graphene is a
result that needs to be to be
established
so in my research i i
did prove that graph
convolutions and therefore graph neural
networks converge to limit objects on on
on microphones and this result is then
what provides the answer to the two
research questions that i posed earlier
right
so uh the answer to the
to you know the fact that gnns scale
well empirically
like uh the what explains that is that
uh graph convolutions and and gnns have
all defined limits on reforms graphene
convolutions and graph neural networks
and this is an asymptotic convergence
result but um
i also developed the final finite sample
version of of uh this result and
essentially what this finite sample
version says is that if i have a graph
neural network with same parameters and
i run it on uh one graph gn and on one
graph gm and these graphs are related
through the single phone right there
they're sampled from the same reformer
parts of sequences that converge to the
to the same reform
then the difference between the outputs
of the gnns and these two graphs is
small
what this can be interpreted to mean is
that dnns are transferable across these
graphs and so we can use that to
generate success on large scale graphs
by leveraging the success the gen inside
the moderate size graphs by training
gnns on these smaller graphs and then
transferring them to these large scale
graphs with small errors so we're able
to upper bound this this error
so i'm not going to go into the details
of the theorems here i do want to say
that i will be giving a talk a longer
version of this talk in
the next graph workshop
but i do want to say that there's an
interesting
results that we uncovered from this
transferability analysis
and
this result that we uncover is that
there is a trade-off between the
spectral discriminability and the
transferability of these linear
convolutional filters that make up the
the layers of the gnn and i'm going to
try to
explain using this plot here why that
happens
so what i'm showing here on this slide
is in red so the red curve is the
spectral or frequency response of this
graph convolutional filter
and in green i have the eigenvalues of
the graph gn
and in blue the eigenvalues of a graph
gm that are associated with the
synchrophone so say that these are two
graphs that are in the sequence that
converges to agriphone they have
different sizes
and
uh
so from graphene theory we know that the
eigenvalues so the spectrum of these
graphs converges to the spectrum of the
graphone and the spectrum of the graph
has the property that it is contained in
this minus one one interval
and it's um you know it's infinite
dimensional so it it accumulates near
zero and only near zero
so
what's happening here is that if you
have filters that are very sharp close
to zero
because these eigenvalues accumulate
they might get scrambled and so what
could happen is that because the filter
is sharp it might amplify eigenvalues
from the green graph and the blue graph
very differently i mean eigenvalues
associated with the same eigenvalue
index right so essentially the same the
same frequency and what this will cause
will be a mismatch so it will create a
transferability error here and if you
compound this error for all of these
eigenvalues then what you'll have is a
larger transferability error
so what you need
to have to ensure that these filters and
therefore that gnns are are that that
they transfer well is we need these
filters to be flat near zero
and i say that this creates a trade-off
in terms of spectral discriminability
because if they have to be flat near
zero what this means is that now these
filters can't discriminate between
eigenvalues close to zero right they can
select any of these eigenvalues
so uh we can expect you know this
tradeoff to be inherited by graph neural
networks because graph neural networks
are just layers where each layer has a
graph convolution and a pointwise
nonlinearity we have a hypothesis for
why this trade-off is alleviated and
indian ends but again i'll elaborate on
that in the longer version of of this
talk
so let me just conclude by saying that
transferability is you know useful and
it's also applicable in practice and in
particular you do see that
in those two application examples that i
mentioned um
earlier in this in this talk
so in the recommendation system example
right so again here remember we have
this product graph we have some ratings
and we want to fill in the missing
ratings so in this setting here what i'm
going to do is i i want to train a g n
to fill in the missing ratings on the
smaller graph and then using use it to
fill in missing radius on this larger
graph right
so uh i do that and then what i'm
considering there on that plot on the
right is the mean squared error of
prediction and when i'm plotting on the
y-axis is the difference between the
mean squared error
on the small graph
and on the large graph but the mean
square error that is attained by the
same dnn and this gnn is trained here
okay
the target graph always has 4 000 movies
here the products are movies and the
training graph the size of this training
graph is in the x-axis here
so what we see when we train these
linear
graph proportional filters and gnns is
that they're
the the difference between the outputs
of the gnn so the transferability error
between the target and the in the
training graph decreases as
the size of the training graph increases
so we observe this this transferability
behavior and again it's interesting to
see that the gnn which
is these two curves here the orange and
the green one
has lower transferability error than
than filters
and then looking at the second
problem now where
we have now
our team of agents we wanted gnn to
learn a control policy to
in order for these agents to flock here
we have the same setting we want to
train it for a small number of agents
executed on a network with 100 agents
and here i'm plotting the difference
between the costs that are achieved by
the gnn by the same gnn on the training
graph and on the target graph this cost
is a weighting of
velocity differences in collision
penalties
and what we see here is that is we
increase the number of agents in the
training graph the transferability error
also
decreases
so uh let me stop here i i just want to
conclude by saying that
i am interested in further applications
of of these results and graph neural
networks to other graph problems in
particular graph problems where you know
existing algorithms uh take a long time
on very large graphs and where we can
maybe leverage this transferability
property of gnns to train gnns in a
subsampled version of these graphs
execute on the large graph
i'm also interested in extending these
results to
sparser graph models right because the
graph is dense and
with that let me stop here thank you
very much
thank you very much any questions for
luana
so i have two well one remark and one
question so let me start with the remark
so another area where graph neural
networks are very useful is actually
applications of machine learning to
other areas of science biology let's say
where many
uh right if you want to understand
cancer it's really important to
understand the pathways which are graphs
and you will have
features which sort of may be some
properties of your nodes there and then
you have a network and people use
graph neural networks to sort of combine
the features
which are sitting on the vertices with
the graph structure a little bit like
the talk rehearsed that's the first talk
in this series
so
and then a very theoretical question
when you showed this picture where you
were blowing up or stretching the area
near the origin of the spectrum
it sort of
begs the question whether maybe there's
an information theoretical
bound where you just can't do better
than a certain
thing because if you blow it up too much
then you just run against the
unavoidable statistical error
and so there may be some square root of
something which will put a bound on you
can't just result
have a better resolution so i wonder
whether you can comment on that
uh yeah i do believe that that will
happen right if you have like sparser um
graphs because
what i think happens if you have sparser
graphs right is
um you could think that
you could kind of like blow up the
gruffle model to the to the positive
like real plane and so if you did that
uh
even if uh
[Music]
i guess even if you still have a compact
operator well you're still well if the
operator is not compact then you're not
going to have this accumulation of
eigenvalues there so it might be that i
mean then we wouldn't be able to say
what we say about this trade-off here
right it is a product of this
accumulation of eigenvalues are close to
to zero
but
i do think that uh
the perturbation of these eigenvalues
that you get from sampling graphs from
your underlying graph model it's kind of
harder to model right it's more noisy so
there might be something
happening there that
would also kind of lead to this
trade-off
okay so um
let me just
um
are
like two graphs
i mean in general how the
transferability is defined
either systematically or just
comparative
is how do we compare essentially how do
we compare outputs of gnns on graphs of
different sizes right
okay so what we do is we look at the um
so we go back to the graph so we look at
the grapho induced by that graph which
is kind of like a step function or a
stochastic block model kind of
typography
uh
and at the griffon signals induced
by these graph signals and then we take
essentially the l2 norm of the
difference between these
okay
thank you yeah let's take any other
questions
offline so that brings us to the
conclusion of this session as well as
the
full series of talks and
the events so thanks to all the speakers
i think all the speakers did a great job
to distill something really
understandable and interesting uh for a
wide audience in 10 minutes i think the
forum was really a success at least for
me i got a lot out of the talks so
thanks everyone and also for the
audience who are here and who tuned in
uh for attending and making this event
uh success so thank you everyone and
yeah it looks like the weather is back
to the typical awesome we take for
granted in berkeley so have a good
weekend and thanks everyone